everything electrolytes how to move
fully into lion avoiding electrolyte
imbalance slash cramps so when I started
the diet I just went to beef and salt
and water and I didn't know anything
about electrolytes I was trying to
eliminate any variable that could be
causing autoimmunity and so I suffered
fairly badly from electrolyte imbalances
around month five I started waking up at
night because my calf was cramping and
calf cramps they hurt a lot and I was
too worried about introducing anything
because of these massive autoimmune
reactions I would have to food or to
even pills or medication just anything
that I just dealt with it almost a year
into the lion diet I realized that
sodium potassium magnesium levels
especially at the beginning of the diet
are super important I found I needed a
lot of sodium about a third potassium
and less magnesium than that some people
need more potassium you kind of have to
play around with it I would say just add
salt at the beginning a lot of salt to
your diet and then if the cramps come
start playing around by adding in
potassium and adding in magnesium and
unfortunately it's pretty different per
person I tried like a third potassium
that's kind of what worked for me so you
can try that but even without
electrolytes the muscle cramps and
electrolyte imbalances do go away you
don't need these electrolytes forever
but at the beginning of the diet it
really really does help
[Music]